it was bruising personally but for the
party it wasn't the end of the world as
some journalists of rent you know we
have Labour's majority it was only ever
SAT number 72 on our hit list anyway you
know I would love to what I'd love to be
in the house of commons now wasn't to be
it isn't the end of you keep and you
keep will go on from strength to
strength it's quite an optimistic way of
looking at the result though isn't it I
mean it's a fifth time you've tried to
be an MP the fifth time you've failed
you were running in brexit central
against the Labour Party that is in
problems to say the least and he still
can't win well look the reason why we
didn't win was because the conservative
vault held up in a way that we didn't
expect that we also expected the Liberal
Democrat thought to be bigger than it
was and we thought that they take more
votes from the Labour Party but as I say
the big one is that the Tories didn't
switcher that's because trees amazed
going through this honeymoon period at
the moment where she's talking the talk
very well and it's harming our vault but
that honeymoon period won't last forever
I think once article 50 is triggered I
think once we get into the meat of the
renegotiation she will begin to bar the
things away such as fisheries I think we
may well end up still paying a
membership fee into the European Union
and the Conservatives need to know that
you will be there if that happens the
same time your personal reputation has
taken a huge battering over the last few
weeks your opponents are trying to paint
you as a fanta cyst a compulsive liar
and to be honest you have provided them
with some ammunition if you look at some
of the false claims have been made about
it that you lost close friends at
Hillsborough that you used to be a
professional footballer they were on the
board of a charity what's going on well
I'll deal with these one by one as for
the board on the charity thing you know
I was asked back in 2009 the charity at
the time okayed the press release so I
don't know what's happened there that is
now a fault as for the close friends a
Hillsborough thing you know that went up
on my website in 2011 I hadn't checked
the website I didn't know it was there
the press officer officer offered to
resign as a result I refused to accept
it because in the end it's my
responsibility and I tu no it's my fault
I should have checked I didn't know
however the smear campaign that started
the week before and the suggestion I
wasn't actually at Hillsborough even
though I've given evidence to operation
resolve and I've said I'd be prepared to
stand up in court on this even though we
provided with
the statements to a national newspaper
was a coordinated and organized head job
on me and it happened because we were
started in the bearish you say it's a
co-ordinated hit job but those claims
were on your website I mean you can see
why labour mps pointed that out well
hang on I mean one of the other
accusations is that I've claimed to have
a PhD you know I've never in my life
claimed to have a PhD you go through the
records no one's ever see me con or had
me call myself dr. not all I came from a
linkedin page that wasn't even my
parents that were on your website in
your name on it well the charity want
what are the false false claim the
professional footballer bond was a
mistake because I did play a from
the age of 13 to 18 but never sound
professional forms and the hills / one
yeah you know I failed to check
something but I want to put this in
perspective you know I didn't lie about
weapons of mass destruction I didn't
send anyone into an illegal war I didn't
say anything racist I've never been
called in a petafile gang or anything
the fact is I fail to check something
which well up on my website in 2011 and
I just think people need to take some
perspective and what happened is that
this story has been manufactured to roll
on because it suits certain people with
the political papers so you could argue
down that you're not lying but you're
just unprofessional they're not checking
on professional I gained it was back in
2011 I didn't check and for that I am
sorry it's my fault but again I think we
need to get a bit perspective on this
you've also of course got to deal with
some pretty big personalities in UK to
say the least that's probably the right
way of putting it and we've seen Aaron
banks one of your parties key donors as
saying that he's going to run against
your only MP using Nigel Farage
described douglas Carswell about NP as a
Tory party posh boy what is going on it
sounds like a civil war well it hasn't
been a good week for you kid I mean I
went away after the Stoke by-election
and as they say you know when the cat's
away the mice have certainly played them
back now the cat's back and you know I'm
gonna sort this out you know the fact is
I was elected but the biggest mandates
in the history of UK upon November 28
calling for unity and that's what you
keep needs to go forward it needs to
hold its Nev it needs to come together
and you need to stay on the pitch
because if it does the bed
it's that we will reap will be massive
because once these brexit negotiations
begin to fail and as I said she be
starts and trees irme starts the barter
a certain things you Kip will go through
the roof when it comes to the polling so
what are you going to do that because in
any other party if someone was openly
plotting to remove the single MP they'd
be thrown out there be stripped of their
membership are you running the show or
is it Nigel fries oh no I run the show I
mean let's be perfectly as say I've got
the biggest mandate in the history of
the party to do so I mean there's been
accusations made against douglas
Carswell that he didn't try to get Nigel
Farage and ninth order at the behest of
myself the fact the party chairman met
with Douglas the other day and we have
now a you know have it in writing from
Douglas that he did speak to the right
people and he did lobby financial to get
a nice I've lobbied myself I mean I've
written to the people that matter I've
tried to get Nigel Farage a peerage and
I think it is a disgrace that he hasn't
been honored in one way or the other
considering when you look at some of the
people who do receive honest Nigel
Farage is the most influential British
politician of the 21st century because
it wasn't for him and it wasn't for you
kid we would never got a referendum and
we would never have got breakfast so did
Nigel Farage and Aaron banks telling you
them before they moved against cars well
no because I was away I went away after
they could have called you up good night
well I'm sort of contact you know I went
away and I've come back and I've walked
into this but the fact is you know
Douglas has put it in writing now it
will now go to the National Executive of
the party who make those decisions and
you know I want Nigel to be involved in
you clip I want Nigel Farage to be front
of house because he's one of the best
communicators in British politics and as
I say he should be given her honor he
should be given a nato's because the
things he's achieved in politics have
been massive are you worried though
about these rumors of douglas Carswell
potentially defecting to the
Conservatives is that something you want
to stop happening what dogus have said
that is one hundred percent that you
kept I never want to see people leave
the party and people aren't leaving the
party actually since I've taken over at
party membership hasn't fallen at all in
fact would open the opinion polls I
think when I took over we were on twelve
percent when I won fifteen percent so
we're going up I mean this isn't really
a party in crisis has the media like
tall is not a rival you know such nerds
not know you know what Sophie I've read
you kept a bit early written 100 times
and I remember when the party really was
in crisis I'm an old hand at this 2006
2007 we were on zero percent in the
opinion polls we'd had the fall out of
killed Roy silk and there was a chance
then of you keep disappearing a party
that is on fifteen percent in the
opinion polls has great things to look
forward to in the future is not
increases at the same time they you've
had whether it's fisticuffs in the
European Parliament as some of your
majors alleged allegedly allegedly
whether it's major political figures
trading blows on Twitter I mean at times
you must admit it's a bit of a circus
doesn't it hasn't looked good attendee
didn't look good actually in the autumn
I think one side took over on November
28 we should smooth the waters and there
wasn't a problem the party was unified
since the result of the by-election and
I went away it's sort of broken out to
gain and now back I've got to get it
under control and I will get on to
control some people will say do you
really need you kit right now because
Theresa May is delivering on breaks that
she says she's taking the UK at the
single market if the polls are to be
believed then people actually think she
is delivering she's doing a good job
well yes you can look I mean many
various beaches sound like you keep
confident speeches at the moment but
she's always been very good at talking
the talk trees ma but if you look at a
record as Home Secretary the proof is in
the pudding that when it comes to
walking the walk she generally failed
whether that is getting hold of radical
Islam or whether that is cutting the
immigration figures down to the tens of
thousands which he said she said she was
going to do in here last year at Home
Secretary a city the size of
newcastle-upon-tyne came to this country
net that isn't a success and I don't
believe for one that she will deliver
the brexit that people really vaulted
for on Julie twenty-third and that's why
you clip has to stay on the pitch to
ensure that it is delivered we talked a
lot about the politics and I'm quite
keen to talk about the personal impact
at the last couple of weeks because
politically it's been pretty bruising of
course yeah personally it must have been
brutal I mean how's it been for you your
hand well it's been quite difficult to
be honest with you the harassment of my
family
is something I was never prepared for
and they certainly we're when prepared
for you know when you have your 86 you
know grandmother having a camera shoved
in their face while she standing there
in a dressing gown whether you've got
your widdle Danti being harassed whether
you've got your parents being harassed I
mean the list goes on and on and on
however and I said this in the
conference speech I won't let it break
me because if it breaks me it breaks you
Kip and I'm more determined now than
ever to ensure that you kid goes on from
strength asleep beneath all that though
you must have had a wobble have you ever
felt I'd like packing it all in well do
you know someone and you do wake up and
you think you know do I really need this
but you know i said when i became you
Kip Lee that I was doing this out of
duty and I have a duty to ensure that
brexit means real exit the hills were
allegations of course must have been
personally very painful as well someone
who is a Liverpudlian someone who's in
Liverpool fan for lots of people who
were at Hillsborough that day will have
been ingrained in their memory can you
talk us through what it was like for you
well I was 12 and a half and you know
it's something which I don't really talk
about that much um you know I was there
with with my father and my uncle's and
we were in the upper tier of the
Leopards Lane End and as I say I've
given evidence head to the police on
this I've spoken to the people that
matter in Liverpool about the situation
and it is quite clear you know I was
there on the day and any scoreless
accusations that have been made that I
wasn't there and I have lied about being
there quite frankly part of a smear
campaign it's been a deliberate decision
not to talk about it in fact cuz it's
painful lord well did you know I just
wanted to get on with my life you know
as I say I was I was twelve and a half
you know obviously I was a young boy
you'd gone to watch a football match
with his family and you know witnessed
things that no child are supposed of
twelve and a half should have to witness
but I will say this i don't been witness
to waste of it because thank God you
know my father was an experienced match
goer and he realized pretty quickly that
something was badly wrong and I think we
were probably one of the face to leave
the stadium I've always seen you in way
as a bit
a reluctant leader it's always as if you
put yourself forward once there were no
potential candidates left in you kids
ranks and I just wonder why that is is
it because you knew you had some
skeletons in your closet is it because
you knew that you're going to take over
basket case at the party what was no no
I mean look I've given my life to
breakfast my political life and I just
thought once breakfast has happened and
you know I've been the deputy leader for
six long years that it was tan financial
and I two hands on to the next
generation we tried to do that it failed
quite spectacularly and then one thing
was going to happen in one or two things
was going to happen in October and that
was either Nigel Farage came back full
time as leader or I stepped up to the
plate to do it and Nigel definitely
wasn't going to come back as leader than
they thought it was my duty to ensure
that you kept remained a political force
in politics so duty rather than a
personal choice then really well it was
my duty you know you know I'm not going
to deny that I I wanted to ensure that
you could lose their to make sure that
breaks it really breaks it to ensure
that people got what they voted for on
junior 23rd but equally I still believe
you kept has a great opportunity in
working-class constituencies to replace
the Labour Party this is going to be a
long term project not a short-term
project and that's why the snow results
may be a dent but it's not fail